mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Bruno Le Maire ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique monsieur le
ministre tout d'abord je tiens à saluer
au nom du groupe démocrate l'action du
gouvernement face à cette crise
énergétique d'une ampleur exceptionnelle
c'est au total plus de 53 milliards
d'euros que l'État a engagé pour
protéger les Français via le bouclier
tarifaire sur les prix du gaz et de
l'électricité mais également avec le
chèque énergie de 100 euros dont près de
6 millions de foyers sont bénéficiaires
ou encore par les mesures de soutien des
ménages se chauffant au fioul sans ces
mesures la facture des Français aurait
augmenté de plusieurs centaines d'euros
par mois en revanche pour les
professionnels si des dispositifs
d'accompagnement sont prévus les
critères d'accès à ces aides sont
vraisemblablement trop restrictifs
partout sur nos circonscriptions des
artisans des chefs d'entreprise et
d'industrie déplorent le critère du coût
de l'énergie fixer à 3% du chiffre
d'affaires mais d'autres critères
restent également fortement l'accès aux
aides le critère du doublement du prix
l'énergie sur la période concernée ou
encore celui de l'excellent brut
d'exploitation qui doit être négatif
face à cette situation les entreprises
n'ont que peu d'options soit elle
répercutent les coûts sur leur prix de
vente et donc sur le portefeuille des
Français quitte à prendre le risque de
perdre une partie de leurs clientèle ou
alors elle baisse leur marge pour
supporter elle-même ses coups mais
combien de temps cela peut-il durer ma
question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre que comptez-vous mettre en
place pour permettre à nos entreprises
de passer l'hiver un assouplissement des
critères d'accès aux aides est-il prévu
je terminerai ce propos en soulignant
que notre action collective a permis à
nombre d'entreprises de surmonter la
crise sanitaire soutenons-les
aujourd'hui plus que jamais pour que
cette nouvelle crise n'est pas raison
d'elle je vous remercie